foreign
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
So today we're going to be talking about
the inhibitor sequence by Aleister
Reynolds now there's three main books in
this series Revelation space Redemption
Arc and Absolution Gap there's also a
couple of short stories in his
collection Galactic North which are
relevant to the inhibitor sequence and
finally there's the most recent book
released in 2021 inhibitor phase which I
have but I haven't read so we'll get to
this one later so as always if you
haven't read this series there will be
spoilers in this video so if you don't
care about spoilers then continue forth
but if you don't want to know anything
about how any of this stuff plays out
then click off of this video so Aleister
Reynolds has crafted an immense science
fiction Universe here and it feels as
though the universe is ancient lived in
we were far from the first intelligent
space-faring civilizations
and yet there is something ominous
though we have encountered some alien
races in this series the universe is
surprisingly silent and everything they
know about the nature of life and the
Galaxy's Hospitality to life indicates
that there should be more so where are
they trying to understand why that is is
a part of what drives this forward
especially this first book so
interestingly enough this first book is
told in different timelines that are
decades apart and that is also the way
that some of the other books are written
as well but eventually these seemingly
unconnected storylines do connect we
start off in the year 2551 on this
planet called resurgum as Dan silvesti
is digging up the ancient remains of
this bird-like alien race called the
amarantins something destroyed this
entire civilization out of nowhere and
no one knows why they suddenly
disappeared did they destroy themselves
did some outside force destroy them
Sylvester is attempting to unravel this
mystery meanwhile in the year
2540 you have the crew of this huge
spaceship called The Nostalgia for
Infinity their Captain is infected with
some insane virus called the melding
plague which attacks machinery and
biology lots of humans in the series are
basically cyborgs and this disease melds
the biological components to the
mechanical components and creates just
like horrifying cancerous gross
basically it's really interesting they
have their Captain basically hibernating
but sometimes they can activate him and
he has to speak through the computer
components because his body just can't
do it anymore he's like so far gone that
the only way they can keep him alive is
to keep him basically is to keep him
basically Frozen most of the time so
these guys are headed to the planet
Yellowstone to Chasm city which is like
one of the most advanced cities
in the galaxy and because they use
nanotechnology the buildings can
literally rearrange themselves and
rebuild themselves and like add floors
and stuff like that the crew of The
Nostalgia for Infinity is headed there
because they think that sevestive will
be there but he won't be he'll be on
resurgum and then we have in the
earliest timeline 2524 also on Chasm
City we have anakuri who is an assassin
hired by a mysterious figure known as
the Mademoiselle who definitely comes up
later in the books anyway huori is hired
to assassinate sylveste long story short
anacori infiltrates the crew of
nostalgia for Infinity eventually and
they head forward circum to find selves
so long story short all of this comes
together and makes sense in the end we
do find out what happened to the
amarantins we do find out who the
Mademoiselle is and why she wants so
that's the dead and how that even ties
in to the mysterious massive zones in
space called the shrouds that some refer
to as Revelation space
so now we'll get into the major Major
Spoilers so if you really don't want to
know anything you should really click
off now so as I said in the beginning of
Revelation space Sylvester is digging up
some pretty well preserved remains of
the alien race known as the amarantins
and these remains are about a million
years old this alien race at one point
had split into two different groups one
group The banished became space fairing
they left the main society but in doing
so they awakened something devastatingly
powerful
this was the power that wiped out the
amarantine race
the banished ones were able to hide
themselves in these zones in outer space
which humans eventually referred to as
the Shroud now eon's past an eventually
different factions emerged within the
Shroud one of these groups wanted to
test whether or not this Force which had
destroyed the main society was still
around another faction in the Shroud
also develops they believe that this is
a bad idea because this could
potentially alert this force that they
are in fact hiding within the Shroud
still so each of these factions creates
a program one manifests itself as the
entity known as Sun Steeler one
manifests itself as the entity known as
The Madame wazow now the beings known as
the Inhibitors which had destroyed the
main amarantin society left triggers
presumably all over that would alert
them if another race became space
fairing Sun Steeler hoped to test
whether or not they still existed by
luring another race into triggering that
Beacon and that's exactly what happens
sylvesty unwittingly activates the
inhibitor Beacon and this of course
leads to a devastating war between the
Inhibitors and Humanity the Inhibitors
were an impossibly old race of beings
left over from an ancient war known as
the dawn War once we got into space
once we left the first system we began
to find dead cultures all over the place
none had survived until much more
recently than a million years ago and
some had gone out a lot earlier than
that
but they all point it to one thing
the Galaxy had been a lot more thickened
in the past
so why not now
why was it suddenly so lonely
the war Corey said and for a moment no
one spoke the silence was only
interrupted when valiova begins speaking
softly and reverently as if they were
discussing something sacred
yes she said the dawn war that was what
they called it wasn't it
and it sucked up all those cultures and
spat them out in shapes and forms a lot
different to the ones they'd had when
they went in I don't think we can really
understand what it was about or who or
what exactly survived it except that
they were more like machines than living
creatures
although as far beyond anything we can
envisage as our machines are Beyond
stone tools but they had a name
or they were given it
I don't really remember the details but
I do remember the name
the Inhibitors vargova said Corey nodded
so if you're a fan of some of the books
that I cover on this channel then you
might be thinking this is kind of
similar to the three body problem the
Dark Forest hypothesis may be or what
happens in The Killing star but you be
wrong because this is significantly
different
and now for the even bigger spoilers for
this series it turns out that the
Inhibitors were actually created by the
survivors of the Dawn War they were
non-sentient beings they referred to
themselves as post-intelligent their job
wasn't simply to wipe out threatening
space-faring civilizations their job was
to Shepherd the Galaxy
through an upcoming crisis and that
crisis was the collision between the
Milky Way galaxy and the Andromeda
galaxy which would take place in about 3
billion years by keeping all
civilizations on single planets or solar
systems it made the process of moving
star systems and planets to avoid
collisions during this time far simpler
and thus it avoided the most amount of
death
however if there was no way for the
Inhibitors to prevent a species from
developing too far into space they would
absolutely commit acts of genocide but
of course humans don't like to be told
what to do even if it's technically for
a greater cause so we get the inhibitor
War which these books cover now these
books are pure science fiction fun I
love a good Space Opera and you really
can't argue with a lot of the logic in
this book and I find that very fun you
can really tell that Alistair Reynolds
really really thought about everything
in this series 10 times before he put
anything on paper this is absolutely an
awesome science fiction series for
lovers of Science Fiction to get lost in
and it's also one of those series that
like there's always another book I would
recommend Chasm city which is a
standalone story about the fall of Chasm
City to the melding plague I found this
wouldn't be really good and also if
you're going to pick up any of these
books feel free to use my Amazon
affiliate link and the description
that's just one of the many ways that
you can support this channel thank you
guys so much for watching make sure you
like And subscribe for more Queens ideas
let me know if you want to hear more
about this series in the future just a
heads up for those of you that may be
interested my next graphic novel the LIE
behind the star is launching February
2023 you can sign up now to get on the
email mailing list to get notified as
soon as it launches more information on
my website link in the description thank
you guys so much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]